[Music]  Selena Gomez chops it off I think people  are gonna be a little surprised we've  seen the 24 year olds with long locks  bangs with her hair up like in this shot  with weekend Coachella and she was  rocking this lob pretty recently but the  super chic and super short style is the  most drastic that Selena has ever done  then I think it was a right decision  singer has been all about change lately  she told et this just weeks ago you just  seemed so happy and like you had this  renewed perspective on life in your  career lately how accurate is that very  I think it's kind of telling I'm very  honest though in general I feel like you  could be able to see in my face and I  love what I'm doing right now it's  enjoying my life and I'm getting to do  things that I'm passionate about with  the people that I love so I'm in a good  spot right now  [Music]  you